jetzt also ampel höchstwahrscheinlich
aber nach wie vor geht natürlich es geht
uns um inhalte und es geht nicht um
karrieren und alle weiteren
personalfragen kommen dann zu ihrer zeit
aber die kommen nicht jetzt natürlich
nicht aber es kann was neues entstehen
deutschland hat oft genug das kann etwas
neues entstehen eben und da ist jetzt
nicht so uninteressant werden künftig in
der ersten reihe mit dabei sein wird
sprich werden kabinettstisch sitzen wird
das im moment das große hobby hier in
der berliner medien war minister bingo
wer wird was das kursieren sogar
komplette listen kabinettsliste schon
und ich habe auch bei uns im zdf
hauptstadtstudio mal nachgefragt bei
meinen kolleginnen und kollegen die für
die ampel parteien zuständig sind was
hören sie so und davon will ich euch
jetzt so ein paar köpfe vorstellen die
ihr vielleicht noch nicht so auf dem
schirm hat und dann will ich euch noch
so ein bisschen was erzählen zu den
mechanismen die bei einer
kabinettsbildung eine rolle spielen den
einflussfaktoren die die beteiligten
berücksichtigen müssen zum beispiel
natürlich vor allem parteizugehörigkeit
geschlecht regionale herkunft
migrationshintergrund alles faktoren die
eine rolle spielen weshalb es für
diejenigen die darüber entscheiden wer
ins kabinett kommt am ende weniger bingo
ist als wir mehr
[Musik]
[Applaus]
nur kurz den bekanntesten namen kanzler
würde in einer ampel ja er hier und
interessantesten ist danach die frage
wer würde denn finanzminister und haben
ganz ungewohnt früh diese beiden hier
interesse angemeldet an diesem posten
und ich würde mal sagen wahrscheinlicher
ist dass erst hier wird christian
lindner denn er wird doch ziemlich
probleme bekommen in seiner partei wenn
er nicht sozusagen kassen waagen würde
in einer solchen ampel konstellation
nach dem motto finger drauf auf die
schatulle das heißt allerdings nicht
dass kay hier zwangsläufig der fall
ihres robert habeck es gibt sogar einige
in berlin die sagen als ein interesse am
finanzministerium auch so ein bisschen
gespielt sondern halb pokerspiel er
wollte den preis in die höhe treiben
weil eigentlich hat er noch was größeres
im sinn nach dem motto es kann etwas
neues entstehen und zwar so eine art
mega ministerium so eine art gepumptes
wirtschaftsministerium mit bisschen
klima bisschen umweltschutz bisschen
verkehr bisschen digitales sowas in
derartigen seine mähne genannt wird muss
man dann mal sehen es gibt auch ein paar
die sagen er bereitet sich darauf vor
innenminister zu werden wir sehr
gewöhnungsbedürftig ebenso außenminister
da hat er sich auch nicht als so
besonders trittfest erwiesen bei ersten
gehversuchen zb hier in der sprechen
diese kopfbedeckung nicht so eine gute
idee als deutscher politiker im ausland
aber das ist ja auch nicht das war
inhaltlich herkommt vom hause her kommt
er hühner schweine weiß nicht was kühe
melken sie dagegen ich komme er aus dem
völkerrecht genau also völkerrechtlerin
außerdem ist er mitglied beziehungsweise
alba das ist sowas ähnliches mitglied
bei diversen internationalen
organisationen sich mit außenpolitik
beschäftigen sie hat sich auch dezidiert
geäußert zu vielen themen der
außenpolitik zum beispiel zum
transatlantischen weshalb viele hier in
berlin glauben sie eine gute chancen
erste außenministerin deutschlands zu
werden
[Musik]
beispiel 1 er hier karl lauterbach hatte
ja schon sehr viel screentime werden
corona manche handeln ihn als
gesundheitsminister und er hätte wohl
auch zeitig stücks mal so aus also dass
ich in diesem bereich schon lange
arbeite ist bekannt und wenn jemand
gesucht würde der also ein bisschen
erfahrung hat dann würde ich
wahrscheinlich da so bestimme nachdenken
nachdenken ja in der spd-spitze denken
sie nicht so sehr über die nachricht von
meinen kollegen und kollegen die sich
mit der spd beschäftigen bessere chancen
werden da zb ihr hier ein geräusch nicht
unbedingt beim gesundheitsministerium
vielleicht auch bildung oder familie
noch mal kurz zur erinnerung klara
geywitz das ist die frau an olaf scholz
seite damals als es um den spd-vorsitz
ging also frau an seiner seite oder wie
sie sich so ein bisschen missverstanden
fühlte das dekorative salat bleibt an
seiner seite die beiden haben damals
verloren jetzt könnte sie entschädigt
werden für die damalige schmach ihre
zwei offensichtlichen vorteile gegenüber
karl lauterbach nummer eins sie ist frau
und der olaf hat auch gesagt wenn er
kanzler ist es für ihn ganz klar sein
kabinett ist auf jeden fall parität und
paritätisch heißt ein bundeskabinett zur
hälfte aus männern und frauen und vor
teil 2 von klara geywitz sie stammt aus
potsdam also ostdeutschland und nachdem
sinnigerweise unter kanzlerin merkel
ostdeutschland sehr unterrepräsentiert
war im letzten kabinett soll das jetzt
anders werden nicht nur deswegen wird
auch er hier hoch gehandelt carsten
schneider wichtiger mann weil der spd
schon der vergangenheit er wird mit
sicherheit irgendein wichtigen posten
bekommen ob im kabinett oder woanders
wird sich dann zeigen dasselbe gilt für
lars klingbeil den organisator des werse
erfolgreichen wahlkampf auch da wird
spannend sein zu sehen was er denn am
ende bekommt hubertus heil gilt
weiterhin als gesetzt aber wir wollen
jetzt nicht alle ab frühstücken uns gibt
es nicht so sehr um vollständigkeit
sondern spannender sind hier die namen
die bislang noch nicht so bekannt sind
[Musik]
manche rechnen zum beispiel mit ihr her
stefanie grubich derzeit
bildungsministerin in rheinland pfalz
und sie ist ein schönes beispiel für
diesen tetris gedanken denn sie steht
für ein weiteres wichtiges kriterium bei
so einer regierungsbildung dazu nochmal
disclaimer vorab es gibt nicht darum
einzelne leute hier auf einzelne
kriterien zu reduzieren ihre expertise
ihre erfahrungen wollen wir überhaupt
nicht in abrede stellen aber es gibt
eben noch weitere wichtige
einflussfaktoren die eine rolle spielen
und sie erfüllt zum beispiel das
kriterium regionalproporz stefanie huber
ist wie gesagt aus rheinland pfalz und
rheinland pfalz ist ein sehr starker
traditionell sehr starker landesverband
der spd und so einen starken
landesverband hinter sich zu haben ist
ein klarer vorteil bei mainz kabinett
will ebenso natürlich private
connections ich meine natürlich ein
belastbares vertrauensverhältnis zu
zentralen politischen akteuren er hier
zum beispiel carsten brosda derzeit
bildungssenatorin hamburg den sehen
viele als künftigen kulturstaatsminister
der bundesregierung eben unter anderem
weil ein sehr enges vertrauensverhältnis
zu olaf scholz hat noch mehr gilt das
für ihn hier wolfgang schmidt der war in
den letzten jahren jahrzehnten immer
ganz dicht an der seite von olaf scholz
bei jedem karriereschritt und wird das
ganz sicher auch künftig sein viele
sehen ihn gesetzt als
kanzleramtsminister der der ist ja immer
so was wie die rechte hand des kanzlers
oder in den letzten 16 jahren neben der
kanzlerin ganz im gegenteil dazu sie
hier sie ist sozusagen er die linke hand
von olaf scholz das gästen sie war ja
die große konkurrentin als es um den
spd-vorsitz ging danach was sie
allerdings sehr loyal zu ihm auch in der
zeit eben als kanzlerkandidat und dafür
könnte sie jetzt belohnt werden sagen
viele zum beispiel mit dem posten der
digitalen ministerin falls denn ein
solches ministerium geschaffen wird fun
fact dazu sie war die erste abgeordnete
die ich hier in berlin getroffen habe
die eine visitenkarte mit qr code hatte
hier schon
ziemlich digital letzte kandidatin der
spd auf die wm schauen wollen sie hier
bei davos geboren in hamburg ihre eltern
stammen aus der türkei sie ist also
repräsentative viele millionen deutsche
würde einem künftigen kabinett gut zu
gesichte stehen sie hat auch gute
chancen auf einen wichtigen posten ob im
kabinett oder woanders wird man dann
sehen bleiben beim stichwort
[Musik]
ganz großes thema vor allem bei den
grünen stand zum beispiel im
wahlprogramm irgendwie unter anderem
menschen mit migrationsgeschichte oft
noch im weg stehen bauen wir ab um zu
präzisieren was das genau heißt dazu gab
es bei einer wahlkampfveranstaltung eine
frage ziemlich konkrete frage die
sinnvoll finden sie auch eine quote für
die migrantische bevölkerung die antwort
geht so die frage ist ja immer was
verspricht man und wie kann man es
umsetzen und wir haben uns intensiv
damit beschäftigt wie würde man dann so
was umsetzen und sind dann schon auch
mit blick auf unsere partei die frage zu
sagen wir definieren von außen wer
gehört jetzt zur quote dazu oder nicht
also zum beispiel migrationshintergrund
heißt dass österreich lettland ist auch
migrationshintergrund ja oder nein oder
ist es nur außereuropäische
migrationshintergrund welche
generationen bedeutet dass
zusammengefasst erst mal keine quote
aber im eigenen sondierungsteam darf man
doch sicher einige mit
migrationshintergrund schauen wir mal
kurz rein
toni hofreiter sven giegold
kretschmann hast du denn man gering
eckard ritter langen
kellner bernburg und
habe
dabei geht es ja anwärter ausreichend
sogar er hier zum beispiel um mit nuri
pure total anerkannter außenpolitiker
über die parteigrenzen hinweg oder her
daniel baier es mit 37 schon
finanzminister in baden württemberg
geworden er ist auch interessant mit
blick auf ein anderes learning bei der
kabinettsbildung sind nämlich die
parteien die allein zuständig sind wen
sie ins kabinett entsenden da kann also
zum beispiel der nächste kanzler nicht
sein veto einlegen zumindest nicht
offiziell
was in seinem fall das wohl auch ganz
gut ist ich habe das gefühl der olaf
scholz kriegt den wasserhahn gar nicht
mehr zu so oft wie er seine hände in
unschuld gewaschen hat ja da ging es um
wirecard da war dann in bayern zusammen
mit einigen anderen kollegen aus dem
bundestag sozusagen einer der
energischsten ermittler so und ein
schweizer im bunde er hier cem özdemir
seit gefühlten ewigkeiten schon dabei
zuletzt war vorsitzende des
verkehrsausschusses ja und im verkehr
mysterium da wird ja auch eine stelle
frei
[Applaus]
so aber da gibt es natürlich auch andere
ihn ja zum beispiel toni hofreiter macht
sie sich auch hoffnung auf den wichtigen
posten kommen aber zurück zu einem
anderen wichtigen kriterium das bei den
grünen eigentlich immer eine große rolle
spielt so auch bei der kanzler innen
kandidatur natürlich hat auch die frage
der emanzipation eine zentrale rolle bei
dieser entscheidung gespielt genauen
vergibt bei den grünen natürlich viele
weitere frauen die sich hoffnung machen
können zum beispiel sie hier steffi
lemke viel erfahrung seit 94 ist sie mit
unterbrechungen im bundestag und zweites
kriterium auch sie stammt aus
ostdeutschland auch wichtig wie wir
gelernt haben beides gilt ebenfalls für
sie katrin göring eckardt manche
vermuten sie könnte
entwicklungshilfeministerin werden wenn
sie nicht sogar bundespräsidentin wird
oder zumindest bundestagspräsidentin für
alle diese posten wurde sie bereits
gehandelt so und jetzt noch ein
wirklicher geheimtipp
oder seid ehrlich da nicht gekannt maria
klein schmeink hat ziemlich sensationell
ihren wahlkreis in münster gewonnen
gegen amtierende ministerin sie hier ist
wenn ihr schulze die übrigens gern
umweltministerin bleiben würde aber
chancen wohl eher ungewiss sie dagegen
maria klein schmeink gilt als sehr
profilierte sehr fundierte
gesundheitspolitikerin und manche sagen
ja sie könnte die nächste
gesundheitsministerin werden also name
den man sich merken sollte maria klein
schmeink maria kann
gibt es da noch hinter christian bleiben
wir mal beim thema
gesundheitsministerium da gibt es zum
beispiel christine aschenberg-dugnus ja
auch sie profilierte
gesundheitspolitikerin oder volker
wissing käme zum beispiel für wirtschaft
in frage alexander graf lambsdorff
außenpolitik marie-agnes
strack-zimmermann
verteidigungspolitik nicola
bergbauernfragen zum beispiel für
bildung und natürlich partei vize
johannes vogel schon in jungen jahren
parteivize geworden und er ist auch bei
anderen parteien beliebte haben gelernt
das ist kein muss kriterium aber es kann
natürlich auch nicht schaden wenn man
zum beispiel bei kevin kühnert sogar als
wg partner in frage käme im moment ist
schwierig weil wir uns niemand ausziehen
möchte das ist ja wie ehrlich gesagt
aber wenn was frei wäre warum nicht mal
musste ich halt ein putzplan wird
beteiligen kein ding hier machen wir
jetzt mal ein strich gibt sicher noch
viele andere namen die man in die
verlosung einbringen könnte aber das
wollen wir euch jetzt mal überlassen ihr
seid dran welche namen könntet ihr euch
denn noch im kabinett vorstellen
schreibt unten rein in die kommentare
kostet natürlich ein bisschen energie
aber hey deutschland hall oft genug ist
kann das neues entstehen
[Musik]